Christopher Columbus has become a
controversial historical figure a claims
for centuries as the discoverer of
America he wasn't he has gains notoriety
for the decimation of the native peoples
that he encountered obsessed with
obtaining gold and slaves in order to
pay off debt and impress the king and
queen of Spain he ended up as an outcast
unwanted in the place that he discovered
and sent back to Spain in disgrace in
this week's biographic s' we're looking
at the uncomfortable truth about
Christopher Columbus
[Music]
there is no agreed upon date as to when
Christopher Columbus entered into the
world
some historians put the date as early as
1436 but others claimed that it was as
late as 1455 the majority agree though
that he was likely born sometime between
August the 25th and October the 31st in
1451 the place of his birth though
that's something we do know for certain
it's the Italian coastal city of Genoa
Christopher was the oldest of five
children born to Susanna Fontana Rosa
and Domenico Colombo the name Columbus
is an English derivation of the Italian
Colombo Domenico was a weaver and an
innkeeper but he was also a keen
Seafarer
and his love of the ocean would soon
transfer to his oldest son as early as
age 10 Christopher ranged up and down
the Genoese Harbor in borrowed single
man sailboats and dreamed of venturing
out into the vast expanse beyond we know
very little about Christopher's early
life but we do know that his father was
able to provide a modest yet comfortable
living for the family and that he was a
kindly involved a man who brought his
sons up with strong biblical morals we
don't even know if young Christopher
went to school it was recorded that he
was of great intellect this little
education and so he may have been
illiterate when he left home at around
the age of 20 still he overcame is lack
a formal education by teaching himself
many valuable skills including map
making functional mathematics and a
range of languages including Spanish
Latin and Portuguese by the time he
sailed to the Americas he had also
learned to read and write
it is generally agreed that Columbus
first went to sea at the age of 14 he
began his maritime career as a messenger
and worked his way up to the position of
common sailor for that six years he
worked on a variety of ships that plied
the European oceans a legend has emerged
that at the age of 21 Columbus tried his
hand a pirate see he was in the employ
of jukka rené of Anjou who had appointed
the young man to capture a warship and
the Tunis Harbor in North Africa on
routes the men with Columbus got timid
and persuaded him to turn back to France
and gather reinforcements the story goes
that during the night Columbus played a
trick on his men by altering the ship's
compass so that they sailed South
instead of North when day broke they
were within sight of the target warship
and Columbus managed to rally his men
for a successful attack many scholars
dismissed the account due to the fact
that Columbus was only 21 which seems
far too young to be given such command
there's more certainty regarding a
voyage that he took two years later the
destination was the Greek island of
Chios in the Aegean Sea he and the rest
of the crew spent a year on the island
in 1476 at the age of 25 Columbus first
ventured beyond the realms of the
Mediterranean and into the wider oceans
beyond he was part of a fleet of five
ships bound for Lisbon in Portugal
enroute the fleet was attacked by a
Franco Portuguese war fleet in the
ensuing battle ships from both sides
went down with hundreds of men drowning
Columbus was on the big hello which was
struck and sunk by a French warship it
was only a stroke of fortune that ended
up saving Christopher's life diving into
the sea he managed to cling to a
floating or and used it as a boy to get
to the Portuguese shore at Lagos some
six miles away luckily the people of
Lagos took him in and got him back to
good health he managed to make his way
from there to Lisbon where he joins up
with a large colony of Genoese
shipbuilders and merchants in 1477 he
joins a voyage to Iceland which he
described as much beyond the limit of
the West
[Music]
returning to lisbon he learns much of
the inner workings of the seafaring
trait this port city was the center of
seafaring voyage and discovery it was
the place where stories of what lay
beyond were told and schemes of
exploration expounded during this time
Columbus undertook the study of
astronomy geography and celestial
navigation in 1478 he set off for the
three key Atlantic archipelagos the
first island group visited were the
Azores 800 miles west of Portugal the
other two were the Madeira archipelago
and the Canary Islands during these
voyages Columbus gained valuable
experience on the open sea on his return
to Lisbon Christopher met and fell in
love with a 25 year old woman by the
name of Philippe Pomona's despite being
of noble birth and with family
connections to the Portuguese Court
Filipa did not come from a wealthy
family when the two were married just a
few months after the courtship began her
father had no dowry to offer the
newlyweds settled in the town of Porto
Santo on the Madeira islands where
Philippe his father had previously been
the governor in 1480 a son was born and
his name was Diego soon after giving
birth though Philippe had died the
details surrounding her demise are
unclear but most historians believe that
the cause was tuberculosis
[Music]
by the age of 30 Christopher Columbus
had developed a great deal of skill and
experience as an ocean Voyager he had
traveled as far as Iceland to the north
and garner to the west still he was
fascinated with what lay further out the
area beyond the horizon was known as the
green sea of darkness and there was much
speculation about what could be found
there darkness was convinced that by
sailing west he would eventually end up
in Asia this was a novel idea and before
he could test it out he needed to gain
academic support for his belief
along with his brother Bartolomeo he
spent months pouring over geographical
maps astronomical books and other
related works when he found anything
that supported his hypothesis he
underlined it and scribbled it into his
notepad
Columbus's study led to three key
assumptions upon which he funded his
belief firstly there was only one ocean
the Atlantic and he believed it to be
narrow his second belief was that the
world was relatively small and that Asia
was much closer to Europe than it
actually ended up being his final
assumption was that there was no large
landmass between Europe and Asia in
hindsight we know that Columbus was
guilty of selective research anything
that didn't support his hypothesis was
rejected outright he gains much support
from the writings of Marco Polo and
first century cartographer Mariners of
Tyre this convinced him that if he
sailed due west he would reach Asia in
less than 3,000 miles
with the scientific backing that he
needed Columbus now set out to find a
backer for his planned voyage of
discovery more than mere financial
support he was after a royal backer who
could garner him the prestige and status
that he would earn by such a perilous
journey in his own words he wanted to be
entitled to call myself Don and should
be hi Admiral of the ocean sea and
Viceroy and governor in perpetuity of
all the islands and mainland I discover
and gain all that might thereafter be
discovered and gained in the ocean sea
and that my elder son should succeed me
and his as thence forth from generation
to generation forever and ever in return
for such honors Columbus would bestow
the riches of Asia upon the sponsoring
sovereign Tabac is cause he quoted from
the journals of Marco Polo about the
riches of the Orient having lived in
Portugal for the past eight years it was
only natural that his first request was
made to that country's king but despite
his persuasiveness Columbus's proposal
it was rejected the king viewed this
unproved sailor as being vain and
conceited and rather prone to bragging
the fact that in addition to honors
Columbus also demanded one tenth of all
income derived did not help his course
even beyond all that the vast majority
of the king's advisers believed that the
plan to reach the Orient by sailing due
west
was nothing more than a fool's errand
with a round rejection from his adopted
country Columbus set his sights on the
king of Spain by now the would-be
adventurer was 34 years of age penniless
widowed and with a young son to care for
arriving in the Spanish port town of
Palos with five year-old Diego in tow he
first set out to find food lodging and a
place for Diego to stay as his father
made his approach to the king Columbus
made his way to a franciscan monastery
overlooking the port and pleaded poverty
for the next five months this monastery
would be his base then towards the end
of 1945 he made his way to Cordoba to
seek an audience with King Ferdinand and
Queen Isabella he had a way for the
Monarchs to return from Madrid during
this time he met a young woman named
Beatriz enric astor harana she became
his mistress giving birth to his second
son Ferdinand on August the 15th 1488
the audience before the king and queen
was granted on may the first 1480
six Columbus and Isabella develops an
immediate bond being of the same age and
clearly they were like-minded still the
Monarchs turned the idea over to an
investigator Columbus would have to wait
for five and a half four straighting
years to learn of their final decision
during that time he had returned to
Lisbon in an attempt to reopen
negotiations with the king there but all
to no avail
in the end the spanish commission also
rejected the plan their main reasons for
doing so were that a voyage to Asia
would require an absence of three years
this was far too long with the available
technology and the belief that if a ship
did manage to get to the other side of
the world there was no way that it would
be able to get back the final decision
however was left to King Ferdinand and
Queen Isabella the king was happy to go
along with the Commission's
recommendation after all he disliked
Columbus on a personal level the Queen
however took pains to reassure Columbus
that he would be able to resubmit his
plan in the future
the Spanish struggle against the Moors
at this point had been going on for 700
years and it was nearly at a conclusion
when this was decided the Queen told him
he would get a better reception On
January the 2nd 1492 the Moorish city of
Granada fell to the Spanish shortly
thereafter the Royal Minister of the
budget who was friendly with Columbus
entrusted upon the Queen to show favor
to the Mariners scheme she relented and
Columbus who was then on his way back to
Cordoba on the back of a mule was
intercepted and rushed to the Royal
Palace
to receive the good news
[Music]
after waiting for five years it took
Columbus just ten weeks to gather
together the three ships crew and the
supplies that he needed his three ships
the Nina Pinta and Santa Maria were
skillfully built and according to him
were well suited for the task at hand
Columbus gathered a crew of 90 men to be
split between the three ships the fleet
left early morning on August the 3rd
1492 the first stop was the Canary
Islands a thousand miles to the south
there the ships were refitted and
resupplied before heading out into the
green sea of darkness the ships made
good progress thanks to strong easterly
winds after some days they entered into
an area known as the Saragosa sea all
around the waters were filled with Gulf
weed a thick green plant that floated on
the surface at the same time as this was
happening the winds died down to almost
nothing
after three weeks at sea the crew began
to site land nesting birds still there
was no sighting of land as the weeks
passed with no indications of Terra
Firma the Creek became increasingly
agitated on both the Santa Maria they
were even close to mutiny with things
coming to a boiling point Columbus made
an ultimate declaration on October the
10th if land was not cited in three days
he promised that he would turn back two
days later the long-awaited word came at
2:00 a.m. on the 12th the cry of Terror
terror resounded from ship to ship 90
pairs of eyes strained to see the
islands that were six miles in the
distance Columbus had promised that the
first man to sight land would receive a
yearly pension of a thousand Mara V
ADA's for the rest of his life yet that
man the Sailor named Rodrigo ever
received this reward Columbus claimed to
have seen a light the evening before and
gave himself the reward there'd come
across an island situated in the middle
of the Caribbean Sea it was populated by
Arawak Indians these were a friendly
people and some of them swum out to meet
the newcomers these people lived in
village communes and to developed an
agricultural economy they had no iron
implements but Columbus was quick to
notice that they wore tiny pieces of
gold in their ears
Columbus was determined to get to the
source of the arrow axe Gold he lured
some of the natives aboard his ships and
then took them as prisoners he demanded
that they guide into the place where the
gold was located not having success he
sailed to modern-day Cuba and then to
Hispaniola it was there that he
visions of a vast gold Empire well
rekindled when a local chief presented
him with a gold mask
Columbus and his men build a fort on the
island of Hispaniola naming it Navidad
Christmas
he left 39 men there with strict orders
to find the gold he then took more
prisoners and began for the return
journey to Spain before leaving his men
killed two natives who refused to trade
as many bows and arrows as they demanded
on the return journey some of the
prisoners died from exposure to cold
weather on his return to Spain Columbus
made extravagant claims about what he
had encountered he stated that he had
reached Asia when in fact he had landed
on Cuba he also spoke of rivers flowing
with gold and and abundance of spices he
promised that with a little more
financial help from the king and queen
he could go back and pick up as much
gold as they needed and as many slaves
as they needed to the king and queen
were suitably enamored the second voyage
was made up of 17 ships and more than
1,200 men whereas the first trip had
been focused on reaching Asia now the
objective was to fold slaves and goals
from islands Islands they raged taking
prisoners and demanding that they be led
to the gold as word spreads of the
impending danger villages were evacuated
and the sailors who had been left at
navitat were executed with no gold to be
found Columbus embarked upon a massive
slave drive 1500 Arawak men women and
children were thrown into pens and from
them 500 of the best specimens were
chosen to be taken to Spain 200 of these
died on the way back with the remainder
being sold at auction
still Columbus was desperate to get his
hands on the gold in Haiti he ordered
that every person aged 14 years or over
was to collect a minimum quota of gold
every three months
those that succeeded were given a copper
necklace to wear anyone without the
necklace would have their hand cut off
the reality was though that there was
hardly any gold to be had apart from
small amounts that can be found in
streams the result of Columbus's gold
obsession was that in two years the
Arawak population was cut in half with a
hundred and twenty five thousand people
being murdered starved to death or
committing suicide Columbus established
his base on Hispaniola and named himself
governor of the island the situation
quickly devolved into chaos though most
of the Europeans on the islands were
sickened many of them were ex-convicts
they occupied themselves by raping the
native women and terror
men and children looting was rampant and
the quantity of gold gathered was
pitiful compared to what Columbus
promised in October of 1495 morale
inspector arrived on Hispaniola in the
wake of worrying reports that had
reached the Spanish Court the inspector
soon gathered plenty of evidence to
implicate Columbus giving him no choice
but to return to Spain in order to
defend himself before the king and queen
[Music]
setting sail on the Nina the forty
five-year-old Columbus arrived back in
Portugal on June the 11th 1446 he
clothed himself in a friars robe as a
sign of penitence and set out to meet
the sovereigns at vergis which was some
500 miles from his landing port on
meeting the king queen he immediately
reassured them there was still plenty of
gold to be had he also tried to convince
them that he had reached the Malay
Peninsula of Southeast Asia as a final
enticement he told the monix that he was
convinced that there was a whole new
continent lying just to the south of the
islands that he had landed on to his
surprise in great pleasure the king and
queen were willing to overlook the bad
reports they had received further they
agreed to finance another voyage
specifically to confirm the existence of
this new continent however Columbus
would have to wait a further two years
before adventuring again this time the
sovereigns insisted that he take with
him colonists rather than soldiers the
third voyage therefore included 30 women
50 farmers 20 mechanics and ten
gardeners along with 30 sailors the
fleet consisted of six ships which
Columbus split into two separate
commands the first three ships headed to
Hispaniola with supplies for the colony
that was located there the remaining
ships made up the discovery fleet with
Columbus at the helm they took a
southerly routes to the Indies in search
of any lands lying south of the Antilles
throughout this voyage Columbus suffered
from terrible pains gout as well as
fever land was first sighted on July the
31st 1498 in the fleet soon made in at
Trinidad for the next two weeks they
explored the area between Trinidad and
the South American mainland sailing
further west they saw land again and it
was at this point that Columbus declared
they had found a new continent
having achieved his objective Columbus
set the fleet northeast paniolo when he
arrived he found the place in the state
of rebellion while he was gone many of
his men had died mainly from starvation
while those who survived were disgusted
at the harsh treatment they had been
subjected to under the nominal rulership
of Columbus's brother Bartholomew but
all I knew was the acting governor while
Columbus was away the rebels were led by
a man named roldan gathering both
spaniards and natives to his cause he
set about the process of overthrowing
the fragile government that Columbus had
established after a period of fierce
fighting the exhausted and physically
ill Columbus and treated with Roldan for
peace terms Columbus gave in to all of
Roland's demands including appointing
him as mayor and giving land grants to
every Spaniard who wished to stay on the
islands with this humiliating defeat
Columbus's only desire now was to leave
meanwhile news of the latest rebellion
had made its way to Spain the king had
sent a man by the name of Francisco to
Bob a dealer a servant of the crown and
a knight his mission was to sort the
entire situation out he arrived in
Hispaniola to discover that a mass
execution of the rebels was underway
displaying his royal orders were to halt
to the proceedings and had Columbus and
his two brothers thrown into irons
[Music]
the three brothers were shipped back to
Spain when the people there saw the
great Columbus in Chains after the ship
had docked they became angry hearing of
this popular reaction the king ordered
that they be freed Columbus's reunion
with the king and queen was an
emotionally charged affair he threw
himself at the Queen's feet and threw
sobs he kissed her hands and feet he
pleaded innocent saying that any wrongs
he had committed were the result of
ignorance and not wickedness the
sovereigns took pity on him and promised
to restore his wealth and titles the
king however was convinced that while he
may be superior at sea
Columbus was no governor of men on lands
still his skills as a Voyager we're an
asset that could be further utilized and
as a result Ferdinand authorized a
fourth voyage to the West Indies in the
hopes of finding a direct route to Asia
however he was ordered to stay well away
from Hispaniola this time it was
strictly a voyage of discovery Columbus
set forth on this final voyage on May
the 9th 1502 his fleet reached the West
Indies in 21 days two weeks later his
three ships encountered a terrible storm
which they managed to see through with
no loss of life the fleet eventually
reached the offshore islands of Binaca a
few miles from Honduras from there they
encountered terrible sea conditions for
38 straight days which tested the men to
their absolute limits finally they found
their way to the Panamanian coastline
here they were heartened to find gold in
abundance they spend the next several
months traveling up and down the coast
gathering gold and then they headed back
fierce paniolo but the weather beaten
and worm-eaten ships they never reached
Hispaniola with the ships taking on
water they barely limped in to Jamaica
the ships were now useless and the party
remained stranded for only a year I need
to be rescued when two ships arrived
from Santo Domingo Columbus and his men
were taken to Hispaniola to recover from
their ordeal but the former governor
knew that he was not welcome there as
soon as he could manage it he found
passage on a ship bound for Spain and
arrived back on November the 7th 1504
[Music]
Columbus returned to Spain sick broken
and disheartened
he was so ill that he could hardly stand
on his own power however he still had
the stamina to demand an accounting of
his accumulated possessions the
agreements that he had made years ago
with Ferdinand and Isabella for a tenth
of all bounty had made him a rich man
and he now sought to claim it as a
result gold was shipped to him and he
was given land in Hispaniola but the
wealth it came too late for Columbus to
enjoy it in May of 1506 his bad health
deteriorated fatally he became bedridden
and on May the 19th the priest was
called to administer the last rites he
died the next day in moments after
whispering in thy hands Lord I command
my spirit he was 54 years of age so I
really hope you enjoyed that video if
you did don't forget to subscribe to
this channel for brand new biographies
every Monday and every Thursday also
I've got another channel that's called
today I found out it's sort of like
biographic but way more broad on that
channel we get deep into all of the
details on all sorts of interesting
stuff check it out through the link on
the screen now but if you're looking for
something else to watch right now why
not check out a biography from the
archives or it's a dare found our video
over there on the right and as always
thank you for watching